[Music]
I see dead people
what if you actually did see dead people
not in a sixth sense kind of way but in
an inexplicable mass resurrection kind
of way not in a walking dead kind of way
but in a holy grandma's back kind of way
while this may sound like a great
opportunity to catch up with lost loved
ones and to meet some of your heroes it
would actually be horrible this is what
eff and here's what would happen if
every dead person came back to life
today there are more humans alive on
earth than there have ever been and yet
that's not really saying much there are
still way more dead people our current
global population is seven point seven
billion which only accounts for about
seven percent of all the humans who've
ever lived on this planet if we go back
about 200,000 years ago when modern
humans began to evolve and counted all
the humans who have been born between
then and now well you'd be looking at a
crowd of about 108 billion people now
imagine all of those people alive right
now how long do you think you'll last
some scientists believe that our planet
can support a maximum 10 billion people
and according to UN projections
we'll reach that number by the year 2100
now still scary but at least that gives
us some time to come up with solutions
for overpopulation on earth so suppose
you're thinking about it over a cup of
coffee one day and you look up and you
see someone you haven't seen in a long
time because they're dead but they're
not anymore
in fact everyone who's ever lived on
earth is miraculously brought back to
life only it's not a miracle
it's a crisis a food crisis space isn't
even the main problem since throughout
all of human history until about the
last few decades most humans lived in
rural areas and that's probably where
most of the resurrected would return to
ironically despite having enough land to
fit everyone we wouldn't have enough
available farmland to feed everyone
so far we've already brought about
one-third of the world's arable land
under cultivation and that was to feed
what is now only 7% of the total
population there's simply no way we'd be
able to feed 100 billion people under
these constraints 90 percent of the
world's population would easily die of
starvation within two months and that's
not even including deaths that would
arise from the world war ensuing over
resources which honestly would be a
really unfair fight relatively quickly
the world population would stabilize at
a reasonable if not a quite cramped
capacity and while it would all be
settled in a few months those who
survive the shock and awe would still be
wondering what just happened while it's
a totally impossible scenario it does
give you something to think about how
many people can our world comfortably
fit what will have to change in order to
accommodate the growing population or
will things simply change on their own
the United Nations claims that in recent
years families around the world have
been getting smaller and fertility rates
are decreasing but is it too little too
late catch up on other big questions
next time on what if